[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
ein weg
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
wie auch norbert lehmann für den sport
ein stück natur von mir wir beginnen mit
der neuen präsidentin des bundestags ich
bin erst die dritte frau an seiner
spitze die dritte seit 1949
in seiner ersten sitzung hat der
bundestag bärbel bas von der spd in das
zweithöchste staatsamt gewählt
zum schutz von alten und kranken
politiker ärzte und patientenschützer
fordern schnelle corona
auffrischimpfungen
und ein jahr bus und bahnfahren für 1100
euro in österreich will die regierung
zum auto verzicht bewegen
das war heute ein besonderer tag in
berlin im herzen der demokratie die
konstituierende sitzung des neuen
parlaments
ein tag geprägt von abschied angela
merkel auf der zuschauertribüne sie ist
nur noch geschäftsführend im amt und
wolfgang schäuble
verlässt die große bühne ein tag geprägt
aber noch mehr vom aufbruch noch nie war
das parlament so jung und so vielfältig
und noch nie so groß mit 736
abgeordneten
durchschnittsalter
47,5 jahre der frauenanteil ist
gestiegen auf 34,8 prozent
auch gibt es mehr abgeordnete mit
migrationshintergrund 11,3 prozent
christiane hübscher über den tag in
berlin
dieses erinnerungsfoto will fast jeder
egal ob schon lange dabei oder ganz
frisch im parlament für ihn ist diese
erste zugleich die letzte sitzung unter
seiner leitung bundestagspräsident
wolfgang schäuble gibt das amt ab weil
es neue mehrheiten gibt und erinnert
nach 49 jahren im parlament an die
aufgabe des hohen hauses hier ist der
ort an dem wir streiten dürfen an dem
wir streiten sollen aber fair und nach
regeln leidenschaftlich aber auch mit
der gelassenheit die einer erregten
öffentlichkeit beispiel geben kann
schäuble bekommt stehen den applaus von
allen fraktionen am ungewohnten platz
auf der gästetribüne noch
bundeskanzlerin merkel neben
bundespräsident steinmeier und sie ist
die neue bärbel bas von der spd wird von
fast 80 prozent der abgeordneten zur
neuen bundestags präsidentin gewählt als
dritte frau in der geschichte und setzt
sofort einen eigenen ton
verstecken wir uns nicht hinter einem
komplizierten vorschlag hinter meinung
von expertinnen und experten ich wünsche
mir dass wir schwierige juristische
fragen mit denen wir es zu tun haben in
die sprache übersetzen die in unserem
land gesprochen und verstanden wird
279 neue gesichter hat der neue
bundestag die spürbar frischen wind ins
parlament tragen das ist eine riesige
ehre
das ist aber auch eine riesige
verantwortung die haben ja heute noch
mal bewusst wird gerade auch für die die
ihn nicht gewählt haben gerade auch für
die die vielleicht um politik gerade
noch nicht abgeholt werden tragen wir
als parlamentarier in riesige
verantwortung andere glauben ihre neue
bestimmung schon gefunden zu haben ich
bin ein engagierter oppositionspolitiker
sollte die union nicht in der regierung
sein und so sieht sie jetzt aus ich
werde regierung kontrollieren ich habe
damit erfahrung in den letzten jahren
sammeln können die damalige opposition
die regierung kontrolliert hat streit
gibt es schon jetzt über die künftige
sitz ordnung die fdp will nicht mehr
neben der afg sitzen die union aber will
das auch nicht und beschwert sich gleich
nach der wahl eine traditionelle
sitzordnung im plenum mit der
brechstange ändern zu wollen finde ich
es nicht gut das spiel und ich
ich spüre ein hauch von arroganz der
macht die cdu hat 16 jahre regiert und
ich glaube was das thema arroganz der
macht betrifft auch mit der opposition
muss die cdu uns nicht erklären was
richtig und was falsch ist das parlament
wählt neben bärbel bas auch fünf vize
präsidenten vier frauen und wolfgang
kubicki nur der fdp-kandidat kaufmann
scheitert wie schon sechs zähler vor ihm
in der letzten legislatur weil es voll
und eng war wurde heute 3g im bundestag
verlangt die 23 afd abgeordneten die den
nachweis verweigerten mussten abseits
sitzen am frühen abend überreicht
bundespräsident steinmeier angela merkel
zum letzten mal die entlassungsurkunde
ihr gesamtes kabinett ist nun nur noch
geschäftsführend im amt
der controller banerjee in berlin was
war das auffälligste heute an diesem
neuen bundestag
ja vielleicht dass es keine sitzung ist
wie jeder andere die erste sitzung eines
neu gewählten bundestages hat eben doch
andere regeln als die ganz normalen
sitzungen ein redner sagte heute das sei
ein festtag der demokratie ein anderer
betonte dass es hier darum gehe zu
würdigen dass es eine friedliche
machtübergabe gebe und da waren sich
doch alle größtenteils einig das merkte
man auch an den redebeiträgen die waren
fast alle geeint durch den wunsch nach
mehr respekt und anstand in der
auseinandersetzung trotzdem gab es auch
heute schon misstöne der
geschäftsführende der parlamentarische
geschäftsführer der afg zum beispiel
bernd baumann verglich den neu gewählten
bundestag mit dem reichstag unter den
nationalsozialisten und erntete dafür
heftigen widerspruch die afg hatte
mehrere anträge eingereicht die von
allen anderen parteien geschlossen
abgelehnt wurden da zeigt sich also dass
sich in der härte der auseinandersetzung
zwischen der ard und dem zdf de und dem
rest des parlamentes hier nicht viel
ändern wird auch in der nächsten
legislaturperiode
unterm strich hat man aber eben doch
gemerkt es gibt viel appell für einen
ordentlichen umgang miteinander und auch
die neu gewählte bundestags präsidentin
bärbel bas hat am ende noch einmal
betont jede und jeder hier im bundestag
seien mit dafür verantwortlich die würde
dieses wohnhauses auch auszuüben und
auszustrahlen das ist ein appell der
eben in die zukunft weist dankeschön
nach berlin chuck und avanti
schauen wir uns die neue
bundestagspräsidentin noch mal genauer
an bärbel bas 53 jahre alt aufgewachsen
mit fünf geschwistern im ruhrgebiet
fußball spielte sie schon als das noch
als männersache galt sie ist seit 2009
im bundestag selbst politischer gegner
beschreiben sie als kompromiss
orientiert und mutig muss sie auch sein
wenn sie künftig auf eine fähre
debattenkultur achten und gegebenenfalls
die abgeordneten in ihre schranken
weisen muss das bunt sagt hat mir ja
alterspräsident vielen dank ich nehme
die wahl von herzen gerne an vielen dank
aus der zweiten reihe in das
zweithöchste amt dass dieses land zu
vergeben hat bärbel bas wird sich erst
noch der allgemeinheit bekannt machen
müssen ich habe nicht selbst den finger
gehoben das stimmt aber ich habe im
richtigen moment ja gesagt die frau die
hier fotografiert hat eine karriere wie
aus einem sozialdemokratischen
bilderbuch gemacht von der bürogehilfin
über das abendgymnasium zum
vorstandsmitglied einer krankenkasse von
der einfachen abgeordneten zur
bundestagspräsidentin in ihrer partei
ist sie eher links verortet gegen agenda
reformen stellen sie anders als olaf
scholz kritisch gegenüber
wenn man vorher schon den weg der reform
mitgegangen ist unter schröder ist man
da schon recht
schmerzlich produkt die erwartungen
anbar sind hoch vielleicht auch weil die
bislang zwei einzigen frauen an der
spitze des parlaments annemarie renger
und rita süßmuth überragende politikerin
in ihrer zeit waren
mit bärbel bas steht nach fast einem
vierteljahrhundert wieder eine frau an
der spitze des bundestags
der neue bundestag wenn sie noch mal
alle details nach sehen möchten zb wie
alt die abgeordneten sind oder welche
berufe sie haben online haben wir das
und mehr aufgelistet in unsere zdf heute
app bei den corona ansteckungen geht der
trend weiter nach oben inzwischen seit
fast zwei wochen das robert koch
institut meldet zehn
1473 infektionen innerhalb eines tages
die inzidenz erhöht sich auf 113 viele
experten fürchten dass die
infektionszahlen im winter weiter
steigen werden umso wichtiger ist der
impfschutz was aber wenn die zweite
impfung schon ein halbes jahr oder
länger her ist wann lässt die wirkung
für wen ist eine auffrischung sinnvoll
fragen die viel unsicherheit auslösen
heike slansky berichtet
bis zum juli konnte sich die berliner
hals nasen ohren praxis von dr vor
nachfrage kaum retten heute ist der
impfstoff zwar kein ladenhüter aber
statt erste und zweite impfungen
überwiegt das interesse an
auffrischimpfungen wenn auch auf
niedrigem niveau voraussetzung ist ja
sechs monate abstand zur zweitimpfung
deswegen sind viele noch nicht ganz so
weiter sind erst drei vier fünf monate
vergangen
die gesundheitsminister der länder
hatten bereits im september die booster
impfung für senioren freigegeben auch
die ständige impfkommission empfiehlt
die dritt im funk für personen über 70
menschen in pflegeeinrichtungen für
pflege und medizinisches personal und
weiterhin für immungeschwächte egal
welches alter die
hoffnung ist natürlich dass mit der
dritten station der die mundschutz auch
für die eltern und immungeschwächten
zunächst mal für eine längere zeit
besteht das wird die studienlage dann
zeigen müssen ich glaube bei jüngeren
und sonst gesunden menschen wird man
nicht alle naslang boostern müssen aber
hier sollten wir tatsächlich die
ergebnisse abwarten die uns in den
nächsten monaten vorliegen werden
fachleute und politiker fordern mehr
tempo mit welchem zugelassenen mittel
die dritte impfung vorgenommen wird
scheint nebensächlich die studienlage
ist nicht abgeschlossen aber also sehr
gut wirken die sogenannten gemischten
strategien dass man auch so ein
impfstoff jetzt zur booster impfung
nimmt den mann in der zweiten impfung
nicht gehabt hat das ist also eine kluge
strategie aber man kann im großen ganzen
sagen jeder impfstoff der für die poster
im funk zugelassen ist in deutschland
wirkt sehr gut eine auffrischimpfung für
diejenigen die bereits seit sechs
monaten den vollen schutz genießen
besonders empfohlen für ältere und
menschen mit vorerkrankungen
lieferengpässe das wort klingt abstrakt
aber wenn man vor leeren regalen steht
wird die sache sehr konkret
großbritannien ist davon besonders
betroffen dort kommen zu den globalen
handels problemen noch folgendes black
seeds viele fragen sich inzwischen was
weihnachten wird ob statt geschenken nur
gutscheine für nicht lieferbare es unter
dem baum liegen werden yasin herrlein
berichtet
es staut sich was zusammen felix tor
italiens größter frachthafen die hälfte
aller waren container für die insel
kommt hier an doch es fehlen lkw fahrer
normalerweise braucht es zwei tage von
ankunft bis abtransport mittlerweile
mehr als eine woche nun ist der hafen
voll schiffe werden umgeleitet richtung
kontinent
der lieferstopp durch den fahrer mangel
ist riesig berichtet und auch andere
faktoren erzeugen einen teufels
100.000 fahrer fehlen auf der insel und
die strengen einreise und arbeits
bestimmung nach dem brett erlauben es
nicht dass der mangel mit fahrern aus
europa beseitigt werden könnte
5000 kurzfrist visa hatte die regierung
genehmigt kaum 100 fahrer kamen nun
warnen spielwarenhändler verweilenden
kinderaugen unterm tannenbaum halbe
lösung lieber jetzt sofort kaufen statt
schauen denn ich habe keinen zweifel
daran es wird im dezember eine menge
kunden geben die nach artikeln suchen
die nicht da sein werden
manche supermärkte sind inzwischen dazu
übergegangen mit foto attrappen leere
regale zu kaschieren
express ist schwer vorherzusagen welche
branche betroffen und welches produkt
nicht zu haben sein wird sicher ist die
weihnachtszeit wird eine zeit der
engpässe deshalb brauchen wir
zusätzliche arbeitskräfte egal ob in
fabriken ob lkw fahrer oder erntehelfer
im hafen kein rein britisches problem in
der korona pandemie doch mit dem brett
obendrauf könnte so aus dem fest der
liebe ein fest der lehre werden
der putsch im sudan hat international
heftige kritik ausgelöst deutschland und
die usa stoppten vorerst ihre
entwicklungshilfe für das land im osten
afrikas in new york tag später noch der
un sicherheitsrat in einer
dringlichkeitssitzung im sudan selbst
blieb es heute vergleichsweise ruhig
ärzte und beamte hatten zu einem
generalstreik aufgerufen
gestern waren bei protesten offenbar
mehrere menschen ums leben gekommen den
entmachteten
ministerpräsidenten so teilte der neue
starke mann general albarn mit halte er
bei sich zu hause fest
ganz anderes thema mit einem
bemerkenswerten vorstoß versucht
österreich mehr menschen für öffentliche
verkehrsmittel zu begeistern seit heute
gibt es eine vergleichsweise günstige
all inclusive jahreskarte das sogenannte
klima ticket geht bei unseren nachbarn
in allen zügen und im stadtverkehr
kostenpunkt knapp 1100 euro
etwas vergleichbares ist bei uns
allenfalls die bahncard 100 für gut 4000
euro allerdings ist deutschland auch
viermal größer das angebot in österreich
bislang ein echter renner britta hilpert
trommeln gehört zum geschäft auch wenn
man was gutes zu verkaufen hat das klima
ticket für den öffentlichen nahverkehr
hält die ministerin
da in der hand ein prestige projekt der
schwarz-grünen regierung
1095 euro für alle busse transurane und
bahnen in österreich jedes einzelne
ticket dieser beitrag zum klimaschutz
jeder einzelnen kilometer im
öffentlichen verkehr ist beitrag zum
klimaschutz noch laufen 60 prozent des
verkehrs sind österreich individuell mit
dem auto das soll sich ändern die öffis
sollen bald die mehrheit haben
österreich will 2040 klimaneutral sein
und investiert deshalb anfangs 240
millionen euro in das klima ticket
umgerechnet drei euro am tag kostet
damit die nutzung aller busse und bahnen
zum start wurden gleich drei und 80.000
tickets verkauft ich sehe in wien und
dann kann die öfter hat meiner familie
nach tirol fahren auf jeden fall wäre es
gibt nichts richtig wenn die
verbindungen nur besser werden dass man
nun mobiler wird auch david österreich
noch investieren 17 5 milliarden euro
verspricht die ministerin für bessere
bahnverbindungen und auch auf dem land
sollen busse bald öfter kommen denn auch
das günstigste klima ticket kann nicht
überzeugen wenn die verbindung zur a und
die nächste haltestelle zu weit weg ist
seit fast sechs wochen ist der vulkan
auf der kanaren insel la palma aktiv
beruhigung nicht abzusehen im gegenteil
sagen wissenschaftler
von einer neuen phase ist die rede
weitaus intensiver als bisher nachdem am
wochenende der vulkankrater teilweise
zusammengebrochen war haben sich neue
lavaströme gebildet bis zu drei
kilometer breit bedrohen sie noch mehr
an bislang sind mehr als 2000 gebäude
zerstört worden
jetzt zum fußball norbert um zur
fußball-nationalmannschaft der frauen
nationalmannschaft musste heute
nachmittag in essen gegen israel
antreten in der wm-qualifikation nach
dem 1 0 im hinspiel gewann das team von
bundestrainerin martina voss-tecklenburg
erneut diesmal aber etwas deutlicher mit
sieben zu null
der schönste treffer gelangen lina
magull die in der zweiten halbzeit
bereits zum 15 0 traf die münchnerin mit
einem selbst aufgelegten volleyschuss
überragend auch die leistung von laura
freigang die in der ersten hälfte
herrlich zurück passte für sara däbritz
die kapitänin zum 2 0 in ihrem 80
länderspiel und die frankfurterin
freigang traf dann selbst zum 30 am ende
das sieben zu null durch die
wolfsburgerin felicitas rauch für eine
überlegene deutsche mannschaft die ohne
niederlage in der em qualifikation führt
schon 2 tage nach dem rauswurf von mark
van bommel hat wolfsburg einen neuen
trainer verpflichtet florian coesfeld
der 39 jährige erhält einen vertrag bis
2023 coesfeld arbeitet zuletzt arbeitete
zuletzt als chefcoach bei bundesligist
bremen und war kurz vor dem werder
abstieg entlassen worden
zweite runde im dfb pokal die heißeste
begegnung morgen abend die münchner
müssen nach gladbach bayern erneut ohne
julian nagelsmann er bleibt wegen seiner
corona infektion home office coach
dino toppmöller er wird auch morgen der
trainer auf der bayern band sein der
chef bleibt isoliert daheim ich hab
gestern test gemacht er war noch nicht
in dem maße so dass ich mit nach
gladbach kann deswegen sitze ich immer
noch in der küche in der aber immer mit
direktem kontakt zur bank zwei mal schon
nichts bestens für die bayern mit dem
chef daheim zweimal schon gewannen sie 4
zu 0 in der champions league in lissabon
wie in der bundesliga gegen hoffenheim
stärke die einschüchtern könnte hätten
die gladbach eigentlich dieses
erfolgserlebnis dieses eins zu eins im
kopf vom ersten spieltag als sie dank
player store den bayern trotzten und sie
die münchner selbst mit nagelsmann fast
zur verzweiflung brachten
ja und jetzt noch einen blick auf ein
sport highlight
2022 die european championships heute
wurde dafür in münchen der startschuss
gegeben der ticketverkauf beginnt 9
europameisterschaften im august wird
über 5000 athletinnen und athleten alles
an einem ort die größte
sportveranstaltung im münchner
olympiapark seit den sommerspielen von
elf tage spitzensport live zu sehen bei
zdfonline dich freuen wir uns ja danke
schön nach vielen wolken und etwas regen
heute gibt es morgen wieder mehr sonne
plus etwas nebel die details hat gleich
katja horneffer bettina schausten freut
sich auf sie im heute journal um viertel
vor zehn wir sagen tschüss sind morgen
wieder da und wünschen ihnen einen
unbeschwerten abend machen sie es gut
[Musik]
guten abend häufig kann man am
mittelmeer noch mal den sommer
verlängern da ist es häufig noch sonnig
und warm im herbst aber aktuell dreht
sich hier ein tief über dem zentralen
mittelmeer das hat kräftige regenfälle
mitgebracht auch gewitter und es
regeneriert sich über dem warmen
mittelmeer wasser immer neu bei uns das
wetter vergleichsweise langweilig da
kommt ein neues tieferen bringt aber
eigentlich nur norddeutschland regen und
stürmischen mit da kann es nämlich in
schleswig holstein heute nacht auch
regnen im süden ist es zum teil klar da
bildet sich nebel und die temperaturen
zeigen ein sehr deutliches nord west süd
ost gefälle im nordwesten sinken die
werte auf 12 bis 10 im südosten dagegen
auf 3 bis 0 grad dort droht bodenfrost
morgen liegen die temperaturen in bayern
meist nur so 11 bis 14 grad sonst wird
es milder besonders am nordrand der
mittelgebirge an der eifel könnte der
föhn für bis zu 19 grad in der kölner
bucht reichen in süddeutschland gibt es
morgen nach nebel und dunst häufig
sonnenschein im norden sind die wolken
dichter und es gibt noch etwas regen
einige regenschauer an der küste bei
immer noch recht kräftige wind aus
westsüdwest in den nächsten tagen sieht
freundlich aus ruhiges herbstwetter bei
temperaturen von neun grad im nebel und
bis zu 19 grad mit sonnenschein guten
abend